ventura boulevard
one of la's top destinations for
shopping and dining on this fame street
is a landmark restaurant called the
freight a bistro owned by french
immigrant andre romillion lafrid opened
in
1972 we were the only french restaurant
on the bulwark right this way
it was always busy even at 12 o'clock at
midnight we were packed after years of
success andre's son alex was eager to
join his father at la frite i was
looking forward to my dad and myself
making this restaurant work for the next
15 20 30 years but two years ago andre's
daughter celine decided she also wanted
it on the family business alex do you
care this going out like this the soupy
you're the boss i know my brother's not
happy that i'm here i know he wishes
that he could just keep going the way he
was going
i think that this restaurant has so much
more potential than it's already had and
i really felt like i could really make a
difference here you haven't eaten much i
could make this at home not in a good
way the food is
mediocre at best what do you need i've
been cooking a la frid for about 19
years i'm responsible 100 for everything
is in the kitchen
i don't think the manual is uh is there
is nothing wrong with it onion soup is
bitter onion soup is bitter martini has
a napoleon complex just give me the
number table he's the little man with
the big mouth
i've watched the food just slowly kind
of go down and down and down souffle's
coming back too eggy
i've made my comments i can't tell
anybody anything um alex
just
i either get argued with or i get told
no oh good old sally
alex he's a little laxatical sometimes
he resents saline i'm not the manager
tonight he feels slighted he feels
shunned my brother and i used to get
along really really well and we were
very close but the restaurants hurt our
relationship pretty bad
i don't hate alex yeah it's you
i know he does
it's really difficult for me because i'm
the one who has to be the the buffet for
both of them and i wish sometimes they
can understand each other
it's so quiet in here the numbers just
cut down to a third of what we were
doing before now we are dead by nine
o'clock
hey we only did about 20 covers tonight
it's going to be tough
i need
chef ramsay to come in
because someone needs to say hey look
this is what's affecting your business
yeah it's slowing down but why do we
need to change things when it has been
working for such and such amount of
years
we're losing money and
it's time for my kids to take over and
if they can work together just have to
close the door
[Music]
before chef ramsay makes the six mile
drive from his la restaurant to the
break owner andre vermillion is anxious
to meet with him privately how are you
today all right welcome to gordon rooney
to give chef ramsey a quick briefing
into the problems of his restaurant
excuse me two seconds hi chef ramsay how
are you hi my name is andre andre gus
here i want to talk to you about the
problem with my business uh first of all
in terms of the business it's been there
for how long the business has been over
there for 38 years wow it's been good to
me
until recently i'm starting to back up
and i want my daughter my son to take
over oh so you're passing to them i'm
trying to and who are they
alex alex is my boy okay
and celine's sister so what is the
number one problem with the restaurants
i think it's mostly the communication
right between my dollar my son but they
somehow it's a big clash ceiling went
and tried on her own business and
it didn't really work out so she came
back and worked for me when she came
back alex didn't want sailing to come
back because he saw the you own the
place
they never really work together it's
really difficult to to find a solution
it's getting to a point where i can
really end all the conflict of
personality and i hope cheer friends it
can help thank you for coming over
good thank you so much nice to meet you
see you shortly okay thank you
hello
how are you i'm great nice to see you my
first name is gail i'm the manager okay
great how long have you been here 20
years 20 years here 20 years wow wow
what's that monstrosity in the middle
there
that's our dessert case what your
dessert cakes is there a problem with
the kitchen or does it always stay here
it's been here for
20 years that i know of
so it came when you came
wow
what is this that's our dessert tray
crap did someone drop it they could have
how long has that break been sat there
that's our homemade bread pudding that's
been there i think longer than you've
been here
huh
well there yeah you're right yeah okay
chef ramsay's right about the dessert
case i think it should be out of here
right where would you like to sit here
yes sir i've been trying to get it out
ever since i've been here
can you hear the noise of that thing the
motor who wants to come out to a
restaurant and sit next to a fridge
constant bus
um is andre around would you like to see
him yes please yeah okay thank you good
to see you likewise good to see you too
dessert fridge is a disaster
andre yes
chef ramsay would like to see you yeah
carlos gasly
[Music]
are you how are you hi yeah good to see
you again my daughter how are you i'm
celine good to see you likewise she's
gonna take care of you
okay
gordon coming here was pretty much my
idea you're gonna look at the menu for a
minute absolutely definitely i'll be
right back thank you
because it's really become a big
pointing finger match of it's
so-and-so's fault oh it's own
self-taught but nobody's taking
responsibility for the problem i'm back
you have any questions for right now
um
what quiche would you recommend i prefer
the lorraine that's something we're
known for let's do the rain the rain and
then i'll start with fruit salad and
then the seafood crepe now thank you
guys this table that's coming in right
now is for gordon
i'll take the la freeze salad to him
chef ramsay would like the food because
all my food is good
how much dressing would you like the
usual amount thank you about three
quarters of start
[Music]
and inside the salad we've got inside
the salad is the romaine the um the
walnuts and you've got your blue cheese
as well and that's one portion it's
massive salads are large and it's
usually good it's an entree thank you
[Music]
wow
[Music]
it's bland
the vinegar dressing is so juicy
the um vinaigrette dressing is so strong
just overpowering are you through with
the salad oh yeah i am yeah
so acidic
yep i already know
did you mention to the chef yeah no one
listens to me
you knew it was wrong you told them but
no one's listening to you sorry my life
but why is that martine doesn't listen
to me and he has an issue taking
anything from a female does this
chauvinistic stance yes some of it it's
absurd i understand disgusting i'll let
them know thank you
i am embarrassed by the food i just
think that it can all be improved
immensely
martin your vinaigrette is too vinegary
okay
you know what is wrong with it because
uh we've been running this food for many
years
martine you heard me right
just letting you guys know what he's
saying okay
i'm thinking this is gonna be the
seafood crepe i'm gonna set that in
front of you here
it looks like a pie
basically they take the dish they line
it with the with the crepes they fill it
with the items fold it back and then
they bake it they're not like your
typical french crepe but why would you
call it a crepe if it's not raining any
crepe
[Music]
i think when the seafood crepe comes out
it just looks like a slurpy mess of
black
can i have a word with your big brother
is he here or not he's unfortunately not
he will be here for dinner service
tonight okay all right enjoy thank you
okay
oh
that that is hideous it's hot in parts
like in the middle but on the side
there's stone cold
[Music]
you want me to take it
is the oven not working no the oven's
working fine you can't surface [ __ ] and
expect customers to float through the
door i understand how long has he been
here the martine
too long you're not wrong there
martine lost his mojo around here many
years ago if you got someone who doesn't
care about the food they're putting out
what do you have
martine he said it's hot in the middle
it's cold on the sides he doesn't like
it
[Music]
thank you
oh [ __ ] how long has that been under the
grill because it looks like it's been
overcooked it's piping hot
is he microwaving that i don't know girl
yes when normally something's that
piping hot like that it always tells you
that it's been microwaved can you just
check with a chef okay i'll check listen
thank you
okay my team
the quiche is warmed in the oven yeah
hasn't seen the microwave
nope
[Music]
chef
um quiche no microwave
i asked him if he put it in he said no
hold on
i'm convinced this has been microwaved
look at it it's congealed it's just like
a rubber puck
sometimes if he gets a little backed up
i i've seen him do it before backed up
this is ridiculous
and let's go and meet martin please it's
a food issue right now that starts from
the kitchen if we had somebody in here
who cared about the food we'd be so much
better than we are now
octane i want you to meet jeff ramsey
come round please
you're the head chef
and everything i ate
for lunch you cooked yes sir
lunch was a disaster
the keychain was
rancid
where did you heat that up was that in
the microwave oven no i disagree
we sat on the microwave and then uh we
put on the oven yes so it did go in the
microwave that is right yes but you just
told me it wasn't in the microwave
why'd you want to lie to me don't you
want me to lie to you i'm not lying to
you i'm just telling you how do i do it
i'm i'm so amazed that you're so laid
back and like you don't give a [ __ ]
talk to me what do you want to say why
don't you care is it because you hate
selena
what does it have to do with cookies huh
because she said to me in the time every
time she tries to tell you something
bang no she jump down here she will come
and attack me
yes sir like saying that i'm me here for
too long it's time for me to go if
you're not prepared to change yeah i
think she's right
if it is time for me to go i go
that was easy
martin
after chef ramsay's miserable
was hideous lunch was a disaster chef
martine is not interested in hearing any
criticism
and is ready to say goodbye to the
freight
martin
the blame is is putting on me
that's why i feel like i've been
attacked
martin
talk to me she just don't understand how
much of the stress and pressure i've
been under that i'm burning out i'm
burning i'm burned i'm burned i'm
oh tell me
do you know how much stress is when i
know that i have to work with her
and i cannot work like that i feel
burned out celine you know overpower
her you know authority is a boss and
there's nothing i can do even the old
brothers runs away from her like you
know she doesn't want to deal with her
that's not right
martin
now i've got your side of the story
tonight i want to see how you cook on a
busy night service okay
i'll see you later
[Music]
it's 30 minutes before dinner service
and celine's brother alex
hey baby arrives to begin his shift any
updates
gordon didn't make me cry he was
actually nice to me
that's nice
um
tonight will be fun chef ramsay's gonna
be coming into this restaurant changing
things so do i feel resistant
definitely
guys look alive gordon's coming in now
good evening hey well hello how are you
doing chef ramsay hi good alex good to
see you so you're the big brother yeah
excellent little sis big brother where's
that
dad uh you know what hockey game tonight
he's what he's gone to a hockey game wow
okay
um two minutes with you catch up all
right so
why weren't you here uh lunchtime um
you're part owner of this business
that's right
but you've never worked with your sister
uh no we work separate nights absolutely
your father came to see me this morning
oh okay to tell me the conflict about
you two not working together
so why is there so much conflict in here
i think the real conflict is the the who
wants to control and what what you know
wants to control things are you
impressed that she's come to run the
business
she shouldn't even be here
i would rather her not be here
but it's your little sis wouldn't you be
stronger and better with your
unfortunately not so what's wrong with
this restaurant in your mind
um
i don't see anything wrong with it so
you don't see anything wrong there's not
a problem with this restaurant anywhere
you know i would change the bathrooms i
would change the different physical wow
i'm not here to make you look stupid
right but you're sounding ridiculous
let me ask you again what the [ __ ]
wrong with the restaurant um
in your eyes there's nothing much wrong
with it
well let's go we'll we'll see
okay
well thanks for the insane yeah
absolutely
hey he's not going to be willing to
accept this
and move on and take it as constructive
criticism
it's not going to work all right you
guys we ready
[Music]
hello there well andre is at the hockey
game hi ladies how are you his two
children celine and alex are working a
rare night together which is good
because the restaurant is packed as word
has spread that chef ramsay is at the
freight salad and you're doing the lamb
special okay
special three working three i'm proud to
be doing the cooking because i know what
i'm doing excuse me when you put things
on the grill there you don't season it
salt pepper on yeah sorry for seasoning
there's nothing on there
right now yeah what do you mean right
now
when we're gonna season them then
yeah right now right now okay now
no seasoning on there they should i
think they don't they salt and pepper
when they put it on the grill they know
they're not
martine
martinez
martine and i have never gotten along he
ignores me i don't get answers alex can
talk to martine but martine does not
like hearing anything from me
what is that that's quiche but it's been
overcooked you're kidding me you don't
listen to my opinions because it's me
martin yeah talk to me yeah come round
please i am talking to you yes sir are
you serious okay one more coming up
i just said to martin would you come
around for a minute he's serving now
you don't walk away and ignore me
[Music]
alex has never taken confrontation well
and you try and talk to him about
something and he just walks away
are you joking around or you normally
like this just sort of given up have you
given up i have not given up absolutely
not we're walking around with a big
bravado it's wonderful
wow this is the most disorganized
restaurant i've ever seen martin the
chef he's burnt out alex well he's so
laid back he's almost comatose andre the
owner who makes all the decisions he's
at a freaking hockey game and the only
one who cares celine everybody ignores
her unbelievable oh by the way the food
sucks
unreal
it's chewy and the sauce is just gooey
the lamb has got like no flavor oh no
i'm sorry
uh
they said the land has no flavor yep
okay
i know why it doesn't we didn't salt and
pepper it they're not even seizing it
bring on the menu let alex know what
table it is please
alex
that's just coming back now thanks
gordon
thanks a lot
is this normal that you don't care
uh-huh celine you know what this is
really this is gonna [ __ ] up everything
you'd better get a grip i can't get in
the middle that's really sad man we've
been running the restaurant for 38 years
and things don't need to change you're
not real
that hurts
i love my brother and i know he's better
than what he's doing here right now
and i wish he would realize that
everybody's here to help
otherwise uh
alex will ruin me
alex
look at me don't bully your sister bully
me i'm not bullying anybody
take a bit of responsibility i am
wow what a [ __ ] sponge
this is destroying us
what a [ __ ] i have to choose
[Music]
it's only an hour into a shaky dinner
service this is gonna [ __ ] up everything
you better get a grip and chef ramsay is
frustrated with alex's arrogance alex i
i can't i'm not gonna get in the middle
as for celine
she is clearly feeling the resentment
from her brother what a [ __ ] attitude
anyways i did this to set him up
stop crying i'm trying so much
stop crying
the anger i can see the anger
it's got to come out now i understand
yeah
every day is a fight what am i supposed
to do i can't keep going
and i feel like i'm the only one
fighting
so everybody looks at me like i'm the
[ __ ] i'm the one who's fighting he's
gonna hate me even more for this
it's fine it doesn't matter
i don't even think that anyone knows how
much i care
i think the man's here to work it out
with you
i just move on i
take a breath and
push through it
that's it there's nothing else i can do
can you call your dad can i can you get
your dad on the phone and get him here
would you uh come here please yeah i'm
ready to go
i tell him it's urgent i will and he
can't be bothered to get his ass over
here to look at the mess that he's left
i'm out of here
[Music]
hi
papa you need to see this right now a
lot of food's coming back you know and
just alex is really just kind of just
nonchalant about the whole thing and
it's really kind of pissing boarding off
the same attitude he always takes papa
you know exactly you know
okay bye
[Music]
andre you've got two seconds
unbelievable first of all i'm slightly
concerned you weren't even here
this is much much worse than i could
ever imagine
the worst thing of all
is alex's attitude he has an attitude
with you or what with me he has an
attitude with himself
why is he so arrogant
it's a problem with him not accepting
his sister
and i suffer you know a lot because of
that yeah you know they can't work
together it's a fire
he hates her
being anywhere near him in the
restaurant whilst they're avoiding each
other oh yeah doing their separate
things the kitchen
is diving it's sinking quicker than the
titanic what's the solution
you can't leave it all to me and i can't
help you unless you start helping
yourself
i'll see you in the morning
after a long night of contemplating the
freak's main issue good morning oh
you're good morning chef ramsay is
focused on bringing this family back
together i can't begin to fix this
restaurant because there's so many
personal problems here
because nobody's opening up in front of
each other i want to try something so i
just want you to bear with me come with
me two seconds okay please
take a seat
i want you to sit
here
watch and listen what's happening
between celine and alex don't leave this
space i'm gonna talk to the celine
how are you good how are you
well good to see you no yeah uh don't
take a seat let's just have a catch up
okay
that was tough
tough night last night
this restaurant's been running for 38
years
but the legacy's not going to continue
with this kind of attitude
the fragmented relationships between the
families is incredible you and alex are
so disconnected how did it get to where
it is today
communication broke down
but underneath all that
deep down inside do you think alex
resents you i know alex resents me
tell me why i think that he feels like
he's the older brother and that he
thought this was his he thought that he
was going to be able to run it the way
he wanted and his world came crashing
down
your relationship with your father is it
different to the relationship he has
with alex
yeah
i think that he thinks that my dad
in the end loves me more for some reason
[Music]
hi hi how are you very good sit down we
were just talking about you oh yeah yeah
why don't you just explain to alex what
you just explained to me
so we used to be very close
but i think that you're bitter towards a
lot of things you've got a lot of
resentment
i don't know if it's only towards me if
it's towards other things i didn't see
you
wanting to to come here
it felt like he was gonna give you the
restroom
i felt like
you know i was losing
not only
the passion and the pride but the
the whole aspect of the restaurant
i still have that uneasy
feeling like
do i belong
i put that wall up yes i did
i can't do i i've said it really nice i
can't do it alone you know that you know
that
i'm not here to hurt you
i'm not here step on you in any way
it was the first time that i got to look
at you in the eyes and knowing that
you're serious about it
the separation between my sister and i
definitely wasn't working and she made
me you know realize we need to get
unionized and we need to get together
with each other and work together i want
to do it with you
[Music]
i love her and of course we're going to
work together with this let's get here
because i don't
i really thought you hated me i think
she needs a hug you're a big brother for
god's sake
we gotta figure out just a way to talk
again we used to talk we used to we have
fun
best friends this feels incredible it's
the most important thing for the
restaurant than my brother and i to be
family for
for us to get along
and for us to love each other let me
leave you guys for a couple of minutes
on your own thank you okay let me get
some fresh air
the walls kind of came down which is
exactly what needed to happen for this
family she definitely showed me that we
need to respect each other and that the
respect for each other is what's going
to make lefree succeed
if we can continue the legacy
and continue the heartbeat of lefree
you've got an amazing son and daughter
there that are desperate to get this
place right
huh
i also
that's one thing i really want is a
three to communicate or talk to each
other and you know it was hurting me
it's
one step at a time yeah that's it
i was watching the old
[Music]
every time we were meeting it was all we
were not talking to each other
both of you are going to have to work
with each other and listen all three of
us are in charge and we should sit down
anytime we have a decision
we need to go one way where everybody
worked together we have seen a big step
on the communication i just opened
across my finger then it's going to hold
[Music]
after a breakthrough emotional meeting
between alex and celine i love her and
of course we're going to work together
chef ramsay is now ready to start
implementing some changes
gone is the 20 year old dessert case
that sat in the middle of the dining
room
[Music]
and in its place a contemporary crepe
station
there you go
real quick let's start doing some crepes
for tonight's menu chef ramsay is
replacing the soggy heavy casserole
crepes
with fresh light traditional crepes try
that
it's excellent yeah it's really good
[Music]
it'll be our first table tonight best
table in the house tonight alex will
once again be in charge of the front of
the house but he will also be
supervising the new crave station and
will be assisted by gail a little fresh
deal on it
and then start to look right as for
celine she will be in the kitchen
expediting and working alongside chef
martin martin you and i are gonna really
need to chat
i'm gonna go completely off the specials
sounds good do you smoke salmon crepe
okay is it all up
what is that it's an omelette
do you want it again you tell me
can he not cook an omelette they should
be able to can i get two new ones
is anybody listening
yes
i'm ready for the
martin try to communicate please
right here
andre martine just stop and come round
look at me look at me in the eyes
look i can't serve that
what's that
it shouldn't be like that like a [ __ ]
oil slick come on guys baba do you tell
him we don't drown it in there yeah okay
he's going after that he has too late
my nine-year-old daughter can come back
from that
martine yes i just want you to care yeah
i i got that
[ __ ] i'm struggling where's the rest of
our food there's a little communication
trying to trying to get everything fired
who's making the crop the show
while the kitchen struggles to push out
food there you go thank you celine
customers who ordered the crepes are
thrilled with what they are receiving
fabulous absolutely awesome as for the
old menu it's disappointment
after
[Music]
coming back
[Music]
it's disheartening to see how much food
was wasted time i literally feel like we
are you know back to square one
so
we just get a little bit organized so i
want to see you step up to the plate
yeah
last night you were the only voice of
reason i could actually understand so
they got to listen got it
you understand
communication is off the essence guys
how many minutes out are we on table 19.
[Music]
in the kitchen chef martine continues to
ignore celine flip that baby
but in the dining room alex is a new man
pretty darn good huh i'm getting my
routine here he's energetic and working
hard to satisfy customers any way he can
ham and cheese including making
delicious satisfying crepes so yummy
isn't it like so i love it it's good
well thank you gentlemen bye-bye thank
you very much
let's be honest we all know where the
problem is
celine
the head chef is not acting as the head
chef and watching the food come out
properly and for every crap dish they
send out
it's closing that door quicker
i have seen what you have seen i have
seen some stuff which i don't like they
need a leader they need a better leader
you're right
they need that
without that they can't respect us
that's the engine room in there
if that's not firing on all cylinders
we're screwed
understand
what i've said absolutely tomorrow i
want each one of you to get ready for
some major changes
[Music]
with the family now all on the same page
chef ramsay moves ahead with a 40 year
old facelift of the freight
good morning good morning good morning
are you ready
to witness the new left reach let's do
it celine ladies first off you go
[Music]
yellow i can't believe i was white how
much does that blue pop out now it's
beautiful how about the awning's gone my
bar americans my bar can be a bar now
it's not smothered with a hideous awning
we've opened up and it's got that modern
french bistro vibe we've got custom
artwork on the wall look at it wow
customer oh my gosh you're going to say
oh my gosh i'm on the wrong
restaurant or what you know it's really
a fantastic change
what do you think what do you mean
it's awesome i think it's just beautiful
look at the two of you i think it's a
new beginning and we're turning that
page from the 70s to the future
[Music]
this restaurant needs to be cool hip
and trendy to compete so the menu needs
to reflect that wow cut down
it's a classic modern bistro take
good
okay tonight we are relaunching lefreet
new restaurant new menu more importantly
a united family with a brand new
attitude to put this restaurant on the
map is one of the most important
worries on my mind last night there was
a glaring problem your kitchen was
nowhere near strong enough to relaunch
this restaurant so i made a few phone
calls and i found a secret weapon
please welcome
chef chewie come here bud
good to see you hello good to see you
buddy
are you good yeah i'm happy to be here
with you guys okay this man has over 15
years of experience in french bistros
whilst i'm here i wanted him to be over
every little detail in that kitchen
teaching your brigade
this menu to make sure we haven't got
issues you got another voice thank you
okay let's go we've got some prep to do
while chef chewie trains martine and the
kitchen staff toilet skirts
chef ramsay reveals the stunning new
menu to the family okay the new menu at
the feet it's gorgeous it smells good in
here already let's have a little run
through on the menu from the top
something classic in french it's cargo
french nails puff pastry croutons in
there mince filet mignon yeah classic
garnish finish with a little cuellar on
the top
the entrees cockavan braised chicken and
red wine swiss chard and turnips the
jaggery daniel braised
truffle polenta and brussels sprouts a
frenchman's dream it's good i i love it
it's gorgeous i'm
just flabbergasted i mean it's beautiful
this is how it should be this is
exciting it's a great menu and you know
i can't wait to see excellent food
coming out of the kitchen oh my god i
mean they're all amazing it's good
that's awesome that's all i know
after almost 40 years without a change
it's relaunch night at la freight how
are you you'll be the first customers of
the new la free and time for chef
martine to be tested okay great you're
set
good
chef chewie will be there to support him
and oversee the crepe station see i'm
here for you long boss
the fruit is gone let's go they're a
little nervous because after 20 years
cooking the same food almost every day
you know the new manual is totally
different
what do we think i have the onion soup
to start your braised lamb shake i have
the tomato sauce
it's 30 minutes into service all right
super sure and appetizers are not only
leaving the kitchen quickly
they are a hit with customers that is
great but back in the kitchen
martin two sipped as yours and a corn
envelope crate
trouble is brewing as a frustrated
celine how's my cord on the look
tries to get answers from martinez
communicate please marty
marty i hear you sir that's me i need
you to start giving an answer choose
celine you need to talk
while an organized celine tries to
expedite
martine continues to ignore
an hour and a half two hours and almost
nothing is leaving the kitchen
in five minutes we'd like a bill okay
we'll leave absolutely i'll bring it
over
how long for this do you think cause
otherwise they say they will cancel it
about five more minutes five more
minutes
five minutes
i have five tables all waiting an hour
and a half for their entrees and i
cannot do anything i am screaming at
them right now
it's too late we're leaving
don't worry about 20. they're walking
out now 20's walking out now
and basically it hurts me so much to
watch any table walk out here without
even getting served their food just
completely out of control
[ __ ] serious man
[Music]
it's relaunch night at the freight and
after a 90-minute wait i am screaming at
them right now uh it's too late we're
leaving
the first table has walked out wow it's
unbelievable don't worry about 20.
they're walking out now
[ __ ] serious man what's wrong none of
my tables have the [ __ ] entrees one
of them walked out they're done oh
[ __ ] how
servers in the dining room everybody
else shut the [ __ ] up for 30 seconds
this is really important celine i need
you to get a grip of the kitchen i need
you to delegate please
i want you to take control please
telling them yeah chewie please take
control of the kitchen yes ma'am thank
you
what's your crepes to
go guys we should be able to do this
come on how's table eight working and i
need like four or five minutes for that
yep perfect what i liked about chef true
is when i said something to him he would
acknowledge me and say okay maybe that's
how it should be okay that's the pledge
with celine and chef chewie now working
in complete harmony we're going to table
seven please
thank you thank you entrees are flying
out of the kitchen
yes
and the freaks relaunch melts in your
mouth it's worth the wait finishes on a
positive note i have no other table huh
i'm finished take a break thank you guys
great job guys thank you
[Music]
right um first of all
let me make something really clear you
will not
be able to move forward
unless you make major changes in that
kitchen i don't know what would happen
to this dressing tonight if chef chewie
wasn't there let me tell you that but
chef chewie can't do it alone
it's true the family's united now
you as a family have to fix the kitchen
yeah gordon made us realize that we need
to work together on making changes you
know building a team that's going to
continue getting this restaurant to
to the next level
and andre when you first came to me you
were worried about these two i won them
together they can work together and they
they proved it
not to me but to you
they are fine
and they just want to make you proud i'm
proud of them
this has been a really really incredible
experience it's great to have made it
through and made it through a stronger
person and a stronger family and and a
stronger restaurant as a whole thank you
thank you oh you were great no more
crepe in a casserole no
promise thank you so much good night
this week we definitely definitely fixed
the family but i'm not too sure we
actually fixed the restaurant we've
given them all the tools it was up to
them to make the tough decisions
sacre bleu
in the days that followed chef chewie
was brought in full time as the new
executive chef just put it out put it up
cordon bleu crepe thank you very much
chewie and is continuing to build a
strong team in the kitchen it's okay
very good crispy bon appetit enjoy alex
and celine are working hard to continue
the family legacy so i need the frise
salad and the pulae
but more importantly they are doing it
together
[Music]
you